bonjour à toutes et à tous ses fans et
aux news l'émission qui fait des news
avec du vieux vous n'avez pas pu le
rater c'est la news paléontologique de
la semaine au cul lui dans avis ce
nouveau petit ce petit oiseau tout petit
oiseau qui a été découvert dans l'ombre
birmans dans le crétacé et qui a qui
détient maintenant le record du plus
petit oiseau jamais découverte puisque
aucune vente à vis est plus petit enfin
le crâne docu lui dans ta vie ce que
vous voyez ici est plus petit que le
plus petit des colibris et il a cette
caractéristique c'est d'avoir vous voyez
toutes ses dents là que vous voyez ici
ce qui en fait un oiseau très basale à
peine d'après la publication
scientifique il est à peine plus dérivés
que archéoptéryx vous voyez car qu'est
opté rixe il est tout à la base des
oiseaux et là vous avez aucune dans ta
vie ce juste après donc ce qui en fait
finalement aussi le plus petit dinosaure
vous savez qu'il ya une petite subtilité
voilà appelé les oiseaux des dinosaures
tout ça tout ça a donc évidemment il a
été occultée d'entente avis a été vendue
comme étant le plus petit dinosaure et
puis ça tombe bien comme il est plein
dedans
voilà il correspond bien à l'idée qu'on
se fait d'un dinosaure tout-petits quoi
donc donc voilà ils ont un petit peu
joué sur cette ambiguïté entre
dinosaures et oiseaux bon c'est sympa
c'est sympa pour vendre la chose mais
c'est pas grave c'est pas c'est pas un
problème
non il ya beaucoup d'autres problèmes
avec au cul lui dans ta vie ce que la
façon dont il a été vendu par la presse
oulala oulala enfin il y en a au moins
deux gros problèmes avec aucune dans ta
vie le premier c'est que c'est peut-être
pas du tout un oiseau d'ailleurs
peut-être même pas du tout un dinosaure
et peut-être même pas du tout un arc aux
ors et le deuxième c'est que il a été
collecté dans des conditions tout à fait
discutable
donc voilà aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de ces deux points là on voit pas
trop discuté de occultes dans ta vie
même mais plutôt voilà de ces
controverses qui entourent le spécimen
alors il ya vous avez pu vous dire en
voyant le truc
ah ouais c'est le plus petit mais si ça
se trouve c'est un bébé non ça ça fait
pas partie de la contreverse c'est pas
un bébé tout simplement parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'os qui sont fusionnés vous
voyez ici sur ce dessin interprétatif
les frontaux sont fusionnés les
pariétaux sont patiemment fusionner une
les prêts maxillaire et les maxima sont
fusionnés donc quand les os crânien sont
fusionnés comme ça c'est qu'on regarde
un adulte pas un juvénile
donc c'est pas un bébé donc ça ça fait
pas partie de la controverse
l'interprétation docu lui dans ta vie
comme étant un petit comme comme étant
un adulte de petite taille
je valide et tout le monde valide il n'y
a pas de souci non non la vraie
controverse
elle est sur l'identification docu dante
avis comme étant un oiseau alors
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi il ya un
problème là dessus pas déjà il faut on
va retourner voir l' analyse
phylogénétique qui a ici donc cet arbre
phylogénétique pour constater qu' il n'y
a que des oiseaux dans cet arbre
phylogénétique vous voyez que le les
espèces les plus dérivés ce sont les
oiseaux modernes
ikhtiyar nice espère heures nice et les
espèces les moins dérivés se sont
archéoptéryx et les drom et aux orres
donc des dinosaures théropodes tout à
fait tout à fait théropodes et le pont
et le problème en fait de tout cet
article c'est que justement il par un
peu trop du principe qu'au cul lui dans
ta vie c'est un oiseau est en fait ils
ont pas envisager d'autres possibilités
comme notamment la possibilité cocu lui
dans ta vie ce soit un lézard et c'est
ce qui a été souligné donc par les
scientifiques chinois qui ont écrit sur
ce site
voilà donc ils ont écrit à propos de
recul dans ta vie ce mais bon c'est tout
en chinois alors j'ai google translate
comme un petit cochon et j'ai lu cet
article
donc voilà ça parle docu lui dans ta vie
ce de la façon dont il a été vendu par
la revue nature's puisque c'est une
grosse publication ce oculi nantes à vis
la même fait la couverture vous voyez de
nice cher donc c
voilà ça envoie du lourd petit
reconstitution de l'animal en train de
voler voilà est en fait ce que pointe du
doigt cet article est basse et qu' il
sait qu'en fait les gens qui ont décrit
occultes dans ta vie sont tellement
partie du principe que c'était un oiseau
qui n'ont pas envisagé la possibilité
que ce soit les arts et ça c'est très
important parce qu'au cul lui dans ta
vie ce justement il a beaucoup de
caractéristiques des lézards énormément
de caractéristiques des lézards alors
l'article
l'article chinois ici commence tout
d'abord par dire pourquoi est ce que
c'est un oiseau
voilà donc bon c'est comme j'ai dit la
traduction est fait à la truelle mais
vous comprenez l'idée pourquoi est-ce
cocu lui dans ta vie c'est un oiseau est
bien occultantes avis a été identifié
comme un oiseau parce qu'en gros son
crâne a l'air de celui d'un oiseau et
s'est littéralement ce qui est écrit
dans l'article son crâne est grosso modo
celui d'un oiseau c'est à dire que
l'oeil et très gros la boîte crânienne
est relativement courte et bombée voilà
donc on part avec un cerveau plutôt
volumineux il me semble même qu'il ya
une reconstruction du cerveau quelque
part je me rappelle plus voilà il ya une
petite reconstruction du cerveau en 3d
ici qui est plutôt globuleux est assez
conforme à ce qu'on s'attendrait à voir
chan oiseaux et oculi dante avis à la
les narines rétracter vous voyez les
narines ne sont pas au bout du museau
mais un peu rétracté vers l'arrière et
ça aussi c'est un caractère d'oiseaux
mais ce ne sont pas des caractéristiques
uniques aux oiseaux nous dit cet article
puisqu'on le retrouve chez certains on
les retrouve chez certains reptiles et
notamment les reptiles qu'on appelle
avis et fall alors reptile au sens
reptiles non aviens évidemment un e
les squames attelé notamment les
squamates et lépide aux orres en général
donc voila et on retrouve ses
caractéristiques chez d'autres d'autres
reptiles et notamment les reptiles avis
et fall donc si vous connaissez par
exemple des panneaux aux russes vous
connaissez peut-être causé aux russes
vous connaissez peut-être peut-être
longy squames à qui des fois et placer
parmi les avis et fall donc voilà ce
sont des ce sont des reptiles qui ont
globalement bas cette tête là
ben voilà une petite tête pointu
généralement des dents relativement
réduite
quelque chose qui ressemble presque à un
bec enfin voilà cd ça et du coup ça ça
pose déjà problème c'est que
l'identification que les auteurs de cet
article on fait donc voici la liste des
auteurs voilà l'identification que ses
auteurs ont fait d'aucune docu lui dans
ta vis comme un oiseau déjà lé pa lé pas
hyper robuste quoi c'est juste une
ressemblance général du crâne et le
deuxième problème c'est que les auteurs
doc eu lieu dans ta vie souligne des
caractères qui sont quand même vachement
reptilien pour un oiseau il y a
notamment la forme des des anneaux
sclérotique vous voyez ici la noce
claireaux ticket préserver et les
plaques des anneaux sclérose de l'anneau
sclérotique elles ont cette forme de
cuillère kouyate très bien donc on voit
très bien cette forme de cuillère
effectivement et ça c'est pas du tout
comme un aux oiseaux par contre c'est
rsa se rencontrent très souvent chez les
reptiles
il y a aussi et alors ça c'est très bien
montré par l'article la morphologie des
dents l'article montre la morphologie
des dents alors c'est dans c'est pas
tellement la morphologie des dents que
leurs positions sur la mâchoire en fait
les dents au lieu d'être dans la
conformation dinosaures c'est à dire
avec une belle racines
en fait les dents docu lui dante avis
elles sont juste posé sur la mâchoire de
cette façon donc ça ça s'appelle la
condition tecau dont tu ça s'appelle ça
s'appelle la condition accroc dont tu
quand la dent est juste posé et oculi
dans ta vie c'est à cette condition la
condition accros d'entre eux dans cet
article du mois c'est ce que disent les
auteurs de l'article document avis et a
eu dans cet article la l'article chinois
ils disent que la condition mêmes
pleuraux dont tu es dans ce cas là ça
veut dire qu'elle est posée la dent est
posée mais sur le côté de la mâchoire
sur le côté interne évidemment de la
mâchoire sinon y perdre et c'est dans
mais voilà elle est juste posé sur le
côté de la mâchoire et ces deux
conditions là que ce soit accro d'hôtes
ou pleuraux donc on ne les rencontre
jamais chez les dinosaures ni chez les
oiseaux mais uniquement chez les
reptiles l'epide aux orres donc les les
arquois
et ça c'est emmerdant ça c'est emmerdant
parce que c'est quand même un caractère
très robuste 1 cette condition de la
façon dont sont organisés les dents sur
la mâchoire c'est un caractère qui est
très très robuste qui supporte très bien
une identification entre enfin qui
supporte très bien la différenciation
entre les archosaures en général et les
l'epide aux ors de l'autre côté donc les
trucs qui ressemble à des lézards donc
là on a quand même un caractère solide
qui placerait au cul nu dans ta vis du
côté les arts de la force n'est pas
tellement du côté archosaures de la
force
un autre truc qui repousse au cul dans
ta vis loin du côté archosaures de la
force celle apparente absence de fausses
quand orbitaire absence de fos en torby
terre qui est reconnue donc par les
auteurs de l'article original voilà en
tord bitale fenestraz reduce top 100
vous voyez ici donc ça ça enfin je veux
dire une absence de fo santé orbitaire
alors que tous les oiseaux et tous les
dinosaures ont une fausse en théorie
terre c'est pareil au moins relictuelle
chez les oiseaux c'est embêtant
voyez là on ne voit rien voici la narine
voici le lay et en gros faudrait
admettre que ça ce petit truc là ce
serait le petit je sais pas comment on
pourrait dire cette petite indentation
ce serait tout ce qui resterait de la fo
santé orbitaire c'est un peu dur à
digérer
donc voilà cet article en chinois là est
très mal traduit il propose des
caractères voyez ici la noce que le
caractère de l'anneau sclérotique il
propose des cartes
il propose des caractères docu lui dans
ta vie ce qui le place assez clairement
du côté les arts de la force donc la
noce clair aux tic
la position des dents sur la mâchoire
l'absence de fo santé orbitaire et il il
parle même du nombre de dents un moment
dont cocu lui dante avis il est très
particulier par son nombre de dents
il a énormément de dents à tel point que
ses dents on en retrouve même jusqu en
dessous de l'oeil
voyez ça c'est l'oeil et il a des dents
jusque en dessous de l'oeil
ce qu'on ne voit absolument jamais chez
les théropodes où les oiseaux vous voyez
là par exemple c'est sas espèrent ornis
et le l'oiseau qui a le plus de dents et
vous voyez que même s'il a beaucoup de
dents elles ne vont pas jusqu'en dessous
de l'oeil
donc ça c'est pas du tout un caractère
qu'on rencontre chez les théropodes en
général et chez les oiseaux en
particulier mais par contre c'est très
commun une fois de plus chez les lézards
donc donc donc donc le truc maintenant
c'est que alors là là où du moins où cet
article ci va et où bon jeu mais je vais
me contenter de le mentionner parce que
c'est dans l'article mais après c'est
quand même faire un procès d'intention
voilà ce qui compte le plus chez oculi
dans ta vie c'est la raison pour
laquelle il a été publié dans nature
c'est parce que il s'agirait du plus
petit dinosaure
or si occultes dans ta vie ce n'est
qu'un lézard
vous pouvez voir que la petite taille
n'a absolument rien d'exceptionnel et
cet article va va jusqu'à dire qu'il
pourrait même s'agir en fait il aurait
même volontairement passés à la trappe
une identification en tant que les arts
juste pour pouvoir atteindre une
publication dans nature alors comme je
dis c'est un procès un procès
d'intention voilà c'est sûr que si ça
avait été un lézard de petite taille
ça aurait été une publication moins
prestigieuses tout de suite voilà
et puis il souligne aussi l'absence de
plumes bon encore que des plumes sur la
tête ça se préserve pas toujours aussi
bien l'absence de plumes ne signifie pas
que les qui avait pas de plumes quand
l'animal était vivant je veux dire c'est
qu'un crâne
par contre eux ils voient des écailles
écailles qui ne sont pas mentionnés dans
la dans la publication originale donc ça
voilà à prendre avec des pincettes
l'absence de plumes signifie pas preuve
d'absence 1 est ce qu'il interprète
comme étant des écailles c'est pas ça
veut pas forcément dire que c'est
réellement des écailles quoi donc
mais voilà il ya quand même un gros gros
doutes sur l'idée
ification docu lui dans ta vie c'est je
pense que le caractère le plus
convaincant ce enfin les deux caractères
les plus convaincants ce sont quand même
la forme de l'année des plaques de
l'anneau sclérotique et l'implantation
dentaire accroc dans tout ça c'est quand
même des caractères qui sont des
signatures vraiment de l'appartenance
soit à la branche archosaures soit à la
branche l'epide aux ors et là on est
quand même plus sûr du lépine aux orres
donc il serait il est fort probable que
dans un avenir très proche
au culot dans ta vie ce redevienne un
lézard et ne soit donc plus le plus
petit dinosaure ou même le plus petit
oiseau jamais découvert mais ne soit
jamais que à nouveau petit lézard parmi
plein de petits lézards voilà est
maintenant le deuxième problème avec
oculi dans ta vie c'est d'où il vient
bah oui d'où il vient au cul du dante
avis eh bien il n'a pas été découvert
par les chercheurs chinois mais il a été
acheté sur le marché noir et lambres
lambres birmans il est connu comme ayant
une origine ugly comme le signale marc
whitten donc marc whitten qui est un
grand spécialiste des ptérosaures et qui
tient un blog dont voici l'adresse et
marc whitten il a écrit tout un article
pour expliquer que quand même
l'origine de lambres birman elle est pas
propre du tout l est pas pour pro du
tout et je vais me contenter de traduire
ce paragraphe qui à mon avis résume tous
très bien et il cite ses sources
vous voyez qu'il ya des sources ici qui
sont cités je vous ai ouvert celle là
bon je vous la rouvre comme ça en direct
je suis comme ça moi je fais et je fais
de l'impro voilà il ya notamment celle
ci qui est qui a été publiée dans
science
donc c'est quand même pas n'importe quoi
voilà donc et en fait il vous résume
toutes ces sources
dans ce paragraphe est ce paragraphe
vous dis mais qu'elle est qu'elle est
finalement le problème avec lamblot
birman il vous invite à aller lire les
autres articles mais en gros voici le
résumé le se marient lambres birmans ou
lambres de me and mare enfin les mines
dambre du mit hadmar sont une série de
dangereux et et trois tunnels creusés
par des milliers de gens à la dure donc
sous des conditions difficiles on hésite
même employer le mot esclave
oui esclaves entre guillemets mais la
comparer mais il se trouve que la
comparaison a effectivement été fait
dans certains de ces rapports il ne dit
pas lequel mais voilà il dit on hésite
même à employer le mot esclave comme ça
a été fait dans un de ses rapports leur
l'horizon le plus riche en nombre se
trouve 100 mètres sous la surface et les
tunnels pour les atteindre
son long et dangereux le minage de ses
galeries est faite par des adolescents
dont voyez on emploie des en emploi des
enfants dans ces mines et pour les mêmes
raisons qu'on employait des enfants dans
les mines au xviiie siècle en europe
parce que les plus jeunes ont tendance à
être plus plus maigre et donc se glisse
mieux dans les petites cavités
voilà les mines sont si étroites que
seuls les gens maigre peuvent y pénétrer
des centaines de mineurs sont blessés ou
tués chaque mois dans l'est dans des
effondrements de tunnels des inondés et
des inondations
et évidemment il n'y a pas de
compensation financière ou deux
ou de soins appropriés pour ses
blessures et il ya souvent des morts
dans la famille des travailleurs comme
si cela n'était pas assez dangereux
les mines sont situées dans une zone de
conflit entre le cash in séparatiste
entre les kachins séparatistes et
l'armée birmane
donc là la région est complètement
entouré de mines de mines antipersonnel
la plupart des conflits dans cette
région qui ont duré depuis des
générations proviennent de deux factions
politiques rivales qui se battent pour
acquérir lambres et les autres
ressources naturelles donc lambres est
l'un des enjeux de cette guerre civile
donc là le truc se trouve en plein
milieu d'une zone de guerre civile et
lambres en est un des enjeux
donc on ya fort à parier qu'en fait
lambres le trafic de lambres sert à
financer justement cette guerre des
milliers de puits pour le sont morts
dans les combats depuis le depuis que
les hostilités ont repris en 2011 et le
conflit est associé avec des
déplacements de civils des génocides des
enfants soldats
dès lors des viols systématiques et de
la torture youpi lambres birman provient
d'une région à la à la terrifiante et
poignant de violence et dans le
paragraphe suivant donc il nous parle du
trafic de nombreux birmans donc voilà
dix tonnes dambre collecter un million
de dollars
dambre qui a été envoyé en chine enfin
bref il parle du trafic de septembre
et comment les chercheurs chinois du
coup l'achète sur le marché noir est l
art le paragraphe encore suivant dit que
la communauté paléontologique certains
membres de la communauté paris
anthologique tente justement de
boycotter ce genre d'article donc les
articles qu'ils décrivent lambres
birmans comme celui là des fossiles de
nombreux birmans parce que justement en
tant que dernier maillon de la chaîne
d'un marché noir de fossiles en fait et
bien les les paléontologues chinois en
fait financent indirectement la guerre
civile birman donc voilà comme je disais
c'est sale c'est très sale il finance la
guerre civil birman et ils financent
voilà des mines des mines qui emploie
des enfants donc vous voyez là on a par
exemple une photo ici dans sa vient de
l'article de syrian ce que j'ai ouvert
tout à l'heure vous voyez là les mines
exploitées par les adolescents envoyez
là dessous je voyais il n'y a même pas
de cordes quoi il descend comme ça donc
voilà c'est sale le lan premièrement il
a une origine assez salée c'est comme
beaucoup des fossiles d'ailleurs qui
sont achetés par les collectionneurs je
veux dire acheter un fossile acheter un
fossile c'est validé indirectement la
façon dont il a été extrait donc c'est
pour ça que c'est très important si vous
êtes collectionneur de connaître
exactement l'origine de vos fossiles
c'est pas illégal de vendre delambre
birman parce que l'ambré considérée
comme une gemme et pas comme un fossile
donc et les gemmes peuvent être vendues
alors que les fossiles ne le peuvent pas
mais voilà ça n'en reste pas moins
immoral et c'est d'autant plus immoral
que derrière il ya toutes ces histoires
de
de trafic et de d'exploitation d'êtres
humains et de guerre civile etc etc
donc voila c'était le point sur oculi
dante avis le point bonheur j'ai envie
de dire donc alors est-ce qu'il s'agit
d'une belle découverte va peut-être ben
qu'oui ptêt ben qu'non on verra bien
s'il s'agit réellement d'un dinosaure
dans le futur et est-ce qu'il s'agit
d'une découverte moral bas là je voulais
se décider après tout j'ai pas j'ai pas
à discuter de ce que vous êtes censé
trouver morale ou pas voilà je vous
remercie et je vous dis à très bientôt
sur un tract aux sciences ciao